- Hey everybody, we're the Try Guys!
- And we're here at the 45th Annual
Los Angeles Pride Parade.
- To show BuzzFeed support
for the LGBTQIA community.
- To everyone around
the world, Happy Pride!
(cheering)
- Let's go dance!
(dance music)
- Tell us a little more
about your organization.
- Well, amBi was founded in 2006.
It's a group for bi
people just to hang out
with other bi people and have fun.
- Are we going to be able
to dance on the truck?
- We're on the top of a car!
(laughs)
- Where am I going to change?
- Yeah, dick's out.
- Zach, your penis is out in public.
- [Voiceover] Dick's away!
Dick's away! We're good!
- You don't need a close-up on that.
- I don't know if I should wear this.
- It's a lot.
- But I'll put it on for you guys.
- 'Cause you bought it.
- I'm a cowboy!
- I just put on a tutu and a jock strap.
- [Voiceover] Guys, I feel self-conscious.
- We're gonna walk across the street soon.
We're about to get into the
main part of the Pride Parade.
- [Voiceover] That's awesome.
(cheering)
- Yeah.
- I love you so much already.
What are you proud about?
- [Woman] I'm proud that we
can be comfortable and open.
No judgment zone. And no hate.
- [Man] Yes, no hate.
- [Woman] No hate.
- I celebrate you. For your body.
Where's the tattoo?
(cheers)
- Go Zach. Go in the water.
Zach's in the water.
- Fuck, it hit me in the head.
- I am proud of this beautiful community.
- I'm proud of this community
and the beautiful people attending it.
- I'm proud that we can all celebrate
us being able to be whoever we are.
- I'm proud of being who I
am and celebrate how I am.
- I'm proud to be who I am as well.
I'm a guy that has a nice butt.
- That's pretty good. That's pretty good.
(cheering)
I just learned something.
- I'm proud to be here
with my best friends
who are straight and also not straight.
- Everything.
- Equality.
- I'm proud about pride
and being pansexual!
- That means you're the
most fun person ever.
- [Voiceover] What are you proud of?
- My abs!
- I'm proud of his abs too!
Look at these abs!
You could wash clothing in
the 19th century on those abs.
- I got a big flag now, what up!
- [Voiceover] What a
great time, this is great.
Everybody's so jovial.
There's also like a billion people here.
- I hope you saw his butt.
- It's a music video.
- What are you proud about today?
What are you celebrating?
- I'm celebrating my two
moms. They're getting married.
- Weddings! I love
weddings! I love weddings!
- [Woman] My dads.
- [Man] Your dads!
You wanna say anything
to your dads right now?
- I love them very, very much.
- Tell me what you're most proud of.
- Myself.
- Moral of the story: be
proud of yourself, right?
- [Woman] Myself.
- [Man] Yes. All of this!
- The best thing about the gay community
is that there's so much love and support.
So much love and support.
Anyone who wants to demean that, get out.
- [Voiceover] And there were like,
400,000 people here today.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, there
were so many people!
- What I think was
really interesting too is
this is such a happy, positive place
and this is such an
open, welcoming community
but even here, there
were anti-gay protestors.
But, instead of fighting back
at it with more hate and anger
the people here fought
back at it with love,
and I think that's the great way to go.
- [Voiceover] Yeah,
always fight with love.
- I think it's important to remember
no matter how far we've come, no matter
how great and supportive
this community is,
there's still a long
way to go and they need
your support, they need to
know that you love them,
and pride is a great thing.
- [Voiceover] Pride's great.
- [Voiceover] The more love you have,
the more love you show, the
better it is. I love you guys!
- I love you!
We love the gay community!
We love everybody.
- [Voiceover] Let's hug the cameras.
- [All] Yeah.
We love you.